[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I have a basket on my kids get up and
they're in a good mood and they're all
smiling there's Mark Bittman close bit
of that
you get that message
[Music]
family don't cost nothing
right your mom's right your best friend
[Music]
yes she could speak flowery both to show
everyone she's small but she's lovely
[Music]
I like being outside like when the
weather's really warm I like looking at
tree
[Music]
me the hon I make is called me as for my
drift is public balance if unfulfilled
time hippie
[Music]
[Music]
it's strangers smiling at Rangers
dancing the strangers community
some of the bike made when he's arriving
at home which makes me very happy
because yes
[Music]
I like um in the bacon sandwich I'm
about to me
it doesn't mix with them we need
so I'd be very happy likely every
friends because they're always there for
you finding dinosaurs in scruples that
makes me happy because it is very
completely meeting different people and
difficulty that gentleman over there you
make me happy cycling with my night same
leg live you do I love people papi
Allah hell off is really really crazy
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
mr. Shetty nyah nyah destoryed amore que
tengo tu mundo
kanako-sama molto Bella so no to van las
Thomas TIA
Adri go unless Flopsy - justanna
grazie Shakespeare's and teasing - listy
visit a toy penguin ogre ona scale a
story Verona Julita elytra jewel esta
arrived on o da quasi-judicial Tonia
Verona's an phenomena K visto Cree
Mentos focus - Tony yeah Nino Vantaa en
el estor a solvent Akane nya nya - telly
lingua
en esta - Laura K defense ato de Crayola
visual esta usted Ruspoli personae KC
dedica no cuesta particularity Gustad e
responder a trade or a AR k vr l
monogamy silver into steadily gödel
Mendo so no co scaglietti Melania no we
do Shyamalan de la Sol de de la tumba
janista atone Soleimani anita are colera
Eric Andre
Ali pre-military cake a Trabant West
Osito Trista coqueiro Punto de todos
aquí está en window a responder a
commando see in cigarettes are usually
safe in here freshly not in case
tomorrow in container dodgy describe a
Julie Donovan meant a un problema no
more equally
consider encanta la historia cerca de
una responder el hermano possible direct
eco co-produced oh oh c'mon we're on a
parole ago he cheated recompense Iole
disconcerted amor a Creed okay Sione del
Sol a 10-day trip osamu ver edit raucous
criminal personas cuanto la morcilla
homo cozy suit Okuma Nadella Kousuke
importation la veta my so no chica trent
a nice ke ke Tom servo ro le damos
Easter a ma la Morena cambiado
importante de Pentimento del amor Iman
Iman Gentry Malan virata's en el tiempo
en el espacio para moon
[Music]
so you think tinder is a recent
phenomenon what if I told you tinder on
paper existed back in the Victorian days
here's what happened way before hallmark
people use personal calling cards to
connect with each other
picture this it was the late 1800s a man
and a woman crossed paths they exchanged
a look in return the man passed his card
see Society at that time was very formal
and not satisfied the fifth social
convention
youngsters got creative enter escort
cards the calling card with a twist
think of the most ridiculous and cheesy
pick-up line you've ever heard written
on a cart come and see our new lamp you
can turn it down so low there's scarcely
any light at all via our sofa just hold
two I'm just your sizing complexion I'm
going in your direction so if you have
no objection I'd like to be your
protection
I am Cy Young who the devil are you now
picture that card slip to you it was a
way to flirt in public we have anyone
ever knowing may I have the pleasure of
seeing you home this evening
and in this case Oh she wiped left sorry
it is the ultimate eternal tribute to
your first love your mom
the I love mom heart tattoo iconic and
beloved
[Music]
the history of the imam centric tribute
dates back to the 1700s when sailors
were at the forefront of tattoo culture
pictures in your staring down a long
studentsí possibly to never return home
these dead sailors often wanted to keep
their loved ones close and what could be
any closer than a heart on your arm
this heart could symbolize the heart of
a girlfriend a wife or mom it is even
said that mom can symbolize a love of
country the motherland if you will but
nothing says I love mom
like this guy Norman college aka Taylor
Jerry Taylor Jerry is the man who
popularized in polarised I love mom
tattoo amongst many others nowadays I
love mom tattoos are as popular as ever
amongst those in the service and
civilians though the imagery has changed
a bit the heartfelt sentiment remains
the same we love you mom
[Music]
my mom is amazing person yeah a little
we are literally was calling you from
tonight captain Yan in Rosario Vargas
our mother and daughter separated by a
border one living in San Diego and the
other in Mexico I came from Mexico 2006
because I want to get another
opportunity so many kids
cuando se bueno en si Nomar espera de
penser came Eva cerberus que la Volpe
Amish
I don't have the permission to cross the
border the line from the last day and a
half
I see my mom to the fence at the side of
the by national park in San Diego the
u.s. Border Patrol allows families to
meet on the weekends loved ones enter
the park and walk directly up to the
border a steel fence
this gives families on both sides a rare
opportunity to see and speak to each
other
no veo el Circo apart a Mira tristeza
male Alegria porque we have air
emissions you know you're going to see
you mom you're going to see your family
but the fans only have a tiny hole in my
mom sometimes
put the seniors in the tiny high just a
little touch it just touch it
awesome perfectly with you estamos
Tresca yellow vests and a hose so my
personal hope in fault call him whatever
unification on April 30th for the third
time ever authorities agree to open the
door allowing floods families a brief
moment to embrace because then we'll
only have three minutes
- no se como various interior a momento
de la palabra - make it worse - goodbye
why now she is so happy because awaiting
their wedding so much this man ever
Oh
[Music]
thank you incredible he was so happy she
was so sweet to me to tell me I love you
mommy I love you so much I love you I
[Applause]
[Music]
would come into church and preach that
God loves me and God accepts everybody
and I didn't believe that for myself I
was walking around wearing a mask
you
I'm Reverend Eric Eric pastor Reinke to
GCC and I am a black gay man ministers
so for a lot of people the idea of being
black gay and Christian are three
intersectionalities that cannot come
together I was 19 when I accepted my
call to preach in the African Methodist
Episcopal Church I was with this
generation of my family at this church
and it's dialogue says you can't ordain
someone who's gay as a minister you
can't attend perform or condone gay
marriage I knew that there was not a
place for me I didn't want that life I
didn't want the sneaking the hiding the
neediness of not being able to be
accepted for who I was as I was I
resigned as I'm resigned
I found a United Church of Christ and so
today the idea that we're looking at is
that I
[Music]
when I first applied to do the pastor of
the church I was very nervous and I
didn't think that they would hack me
again I said I'm gay I'm young I'm black
I said okay
it is extremely liberating to be able to
come to church to be able to stand
before people and to be loved
and affirmed for who I am as I am
without hesitation without fear and
knowing that it simultaneously empowers
others to do the same
you
Oh